movie discussion news and interviews
press one
popcorn talk we talk movies
ladies and gentlemen welcome to screen
junkies movie fights powered by the
popcorn talk network now your host andy
signor
greetings screen junkies welcome once
again to another episode of movie fights
before we start i need to thank dan
merle for stepping in for me last week i
was in cancun guys it was pretty awesome
but i did watch you guys i held it up
great uh thank you uh let's get right to
this man there's so much news this week
uh to tease up what we've got coming
hunger games is up and so we're going to
talk about which superhero would win the
hunger games yes it's kind of a silly
question but it's going to be an awesome
fight also
dream schwarzenegger sequels there's
talk of him making war what one would we
actually really want to see uh the new
x-men casting do we care about it uh and
also the cgi peanuts movie uh is that
good do we think it's a blasphemy so
lots of fun stuff stick around as always
if you don't know if you don't like a
fight you can always click the bottom
right corner to pick your fight and zoom
to another fight so please don't uh
leave your board there's plenty more you
can watch so let's get right to this um
oh before i saw also you always guys
that say you never tease the honest
trailer i'm going to give you a tip the
last fight is always a tease to our
honest trailer so stay tuned for the
last fight and we will tell you a tease
and it'll be related to the honest
trailer a riddle so all that said
awesome i'm so excited uh let's meet our
fighters
first up he is the head writer of honest
trailers and honest game trailers and he
wrote an episode of a tyler perry show
calling me out uh it's true yeah spencer
gilbert yeah
how's it going you should be proud of
that yeah i'm super proud i also uh play
the character adnan on cereal
oh did you do it
you have to watch and find out next to
him he was such a fan i mean he became
such a the fans were going crazy for him
last uh last episode he was in we had to
bring him back you are really nick
mundy's i think mortal enemy now but
it's roger barr for my mockery and uh
bobo's big adventure thanks for coming
back thank you and thanks for everyone
asking me back uh and i'm looking
forward to murdering nick in the future
i'm calling him out right now he's
scared he didn't show up today you're
here in his place so yeah are you going
to keep the energy up i hope oh you know
i will good better otherwise you're not
going to whisper fast and the furious in
his ear and watch it happen
i'm furious this is the worst movie ever
next the rock is a hack oh
i'm so glad to have our first shmo debut
on this show it's the cute one as hal
calls him thank you i'm partial to
christian no offense
but it's the wonderful mark ellis mark
thanks for being here thank you guys for
having me i've been watching a lot of
nick mundy game footage so i feel like i
can bring something of his spirit to the
show today
i hope so you better you're in the mundy
seat so
i get i actually feel angry or sitting
in the corner like this i don't know if
it's
just possessed if this is like a
conjuring situation where it's
annabelle's floated into me and now i'm
just going to be nick let the hey let's
hope and before we start i do have to
introduce our our new recurring feature
it's the dan cam if we cut to dan merle
he's been such a hit uh that we are
continuing the fact-checking of uh mr
dan merle hashtag dan cam please go
let's make it trending yes uh i think
thanks dan how are you doing i'm doing
good it's back to be you know it's good
to be back over here on this thing i've
only ever done one other time
i think we're calling you it feels like
it's always just feels right but a lot
less pressure on this side it's kind of
nerve-wracking to see dan sit there
because he's got his laptop and he's
almost like he's got his hands like an
old gunslinger he's just ready to
fact-check and kill somebody out of the
way that's what he's here for so again
for those who haven't seen the show
before we're here to debate movie nerdy
topics i'm gonna be the judge i'm gonna
try and be as impartial as i can i'm
gonna base it on creativity passion and
just overall just awesomeness and if
there's anything that goes wrong that
even i miss we've got dan and the dan
cam ready to pounce i think we should
call it the damn cam i think we should
damn damn damn you may feel that way if
you can hashtag damn cam awesome so
don't forget we're also on itunes if you
listen right there please subscribe and
i gotta thank popcorntalk network for
being here but let's get right to the
battles and in the way great words of
ken watanabe
let them fight
never gets old round one
not yet kind of anti-climactic
hunger games mockingjay opens this
weekend big news obviously this is the
third movie um in the franchise and the
previous two have been huge hits it just
opens up the fight of number one
does the hunger games suck is it a great
franchise is it overrated is underrated
let's just really get to it i want to
get into your feelings um do we love
this franchise do we not uh spencer what
do you think i don't think it sucks i
mean it's pretty good as far as young
adult entertainment goes and we have to
remember this is aimed at little girls
so the fact that we can get any
enjoyment out of it at all is a bonus i
mean when you think back to the 90s and
the early 2000s what people in that
demographic were watching it was like
she's all that twilight twilight well
yeah twilight was earlier and then but
even earlier than that like uh can't
hardly wait and these like weird uh
tweeny bopper rom-coms is what that uh
demo would be into so my future daughter
i would much rather show her like uh
children killing each other
revolutionary genocide of dystopia then
you know more high school musical roger
um yeah i i don't i don't think it's as
that bad of a series or anything like
that i don't think they need to extend
this last one into two separate films um
it's uh it's it's not the most original
thing i mean battle royale of course um
but it's they're fun movies they're
they're not that bad to go see uh it's
got a great casting uh you know you got
uh woody harrelson elizabeth banks uh
uh yeah i i think katniss is a fun
character to follow along like through
her struggles and all and just see how
everyone is going to kill each other
essentially but um yeah it's
they're they're good movies they're not
like great they're they don't i don't
think they deserve to be as you know
celebrated as they are or anything but
yeah they're
i'd certainly rather kids be watching
that than twilight or something this is
becoming a heated battle mark
what do you think i'm gonna say the
hunger games also does not suck suck is
such a strong word to use i mean
twilight sucks okay but the hunger games
are very watchable they're well-made
movies and the acting's pretty good and
then the the way that they tell the
story especially in this last one if you
haven't seen it yet is it 140 or 150
million opening weekend good nothing is
that good nothing in life is worth 150
million dollars over three days but the
hunger games is entertaining to watch
and i know that they're marketed towards
the teeny bopper demographic but like
cartoons are in for little kids toy
stories ain't for little kids but adults
can go and enjoy that too i think adults
can like the hunger games too all right
i got to bring in a new feature i want
to see if anybody's willing but we're
going to last we've got a terrible prop
this week we have a much better prop
it's the devil's advocate dvd
but this is our new featured devil's
advocate if you would like to vote
change your side and vote against the
hunger games you will win double points
this round would anyone like to say the
hunger game sucks oh i'll pounce on
double point
spencer playing devil's advocate does
the hunger games suck okay i mean i
wrote the honest trailer i can just
rehash some of that first of all um but
really
when you brought up their well-made
movies yeah we're forgetting the first
one that looked like a student film like
someone was running around west virginia
with a gopro on their helmet like it was
the shakiest uh it looked so bad
compared to the other two so i got that
going for it um
katniss is not a good role model
i don't know where that came from that
girls should be like katniss i don't
throw the word uh she she stands up for
herself she she's not doing what she's
told and all that what she does one
thing in the entire movie which is a
volunteer for a little sister then after
that she's just being manipulated and
carried through the games and she's so
reactive to everything that happens like
all the guys do all the saving and all
the killing for her and she's just kind
of like oh peter
she's doing some killing what are you
talking about but she also becomes a
symbol for something greater and she's a
reluctant hero and it teaches kids that
look sometimes you're going to be in a
situation where you may not want to have
to stand up for something but you have
no choice and as this rebellion gets
further into it it's either that or the
capital and do you side with president
snow or do you side with the mockingjay
she's a symbol it's kind of like batman
it's not as good as batman but it's
batman where you can be a symbol is
greater than the person always has
anyone here seen the new one yeah yes
okay let me i haven't seen the new one
can someone just clarify does she spend
the movie looking for peta oh 100
100 she's walking around the chart
spoiler charred remains
district 12
and she's still like but where's peeta
really yeah but after all like where's
my boyfriend okay look in her defense
peter's really short and he's really
hard like he's not the easiest guy like
if you're looking for liam hemsworth
yeah he's tall he's right there nina
could be under some rubble nice
but it is so hung up they put the
romance so front and center on this
dystopian thing where there's such
bigger issues at play there is this
rebellion there is a genocide going on
and it's so focused on oh gail or peta
oh i don't know they're both so hunky
have you seen the dystopian future
there's nothing else but sex to do in
there
i'll either go shoot a deer with an
arrow or i can get laid like that's all
you have to do you're forgetting all the
good fashion that exists in this
dystopian future yeah you can watch them
not forget on your flat screen hologram
tv but you can't you know get food yeah
i mean uh until until i can twirl around
360 and have my dress turn on fire i'm
not gonna be satisfied you know i want
that and a hoverboard yeah that's
another thing is the world is not really
fleshed out i know it is in the books um
but i shouldn't have to do homework to
enjoy the movies they never give you
like reasons why
it is this way why the uh these
districts have allowed their children to
murder each other for 75 years without
rising up until you know katniss is well
it's because the middle class went so
far away that you just had the haves and
the has-nots and it became such an
extreme situation where the only thing
that you can do is try to survive or
fall in a love triangle but then like
where does the capital get all that
money and flying spaceships from like
where's the industry it's so sad how we
watch movies now isn't it
i can't turn it on
listen i'm playing devil's advocate
right here this is not what i really
think i'm just doing this for the sake
of movie fights uh i guess that's my
case
well look it's an interesting debate but
also it's not battle royale that's a
huge one that's a good that's a good
point right i i where i struggle and i'm
being trying to be impartial because i
might and i'd like just to help defend
like
and if she does it again in the new one
that makes me even more mad but like at
the end of catching fire they've just
literally destroyed the hunger games
she's and she's not in on it they're
about to have a rebellion this clearly
this society is not proper and her first
thing is where's peter how did you lie
to me and where's pete like to me that's
not a strong heroine like is she does
she kill people in the new one the new
one does she like get a little bit more
aggressive you know that one scene where
you see her shoot an arrow at the ship
and it crashes into each other that's
the one thing she does so the
non-devil's advocate person who loves
the movies does she stand up and and
she does because she grows into the
mockingjay symbol because everybody else
needs a they need to pinpoint why we are
a rebellion and what we're standing up
for and that is what she is and when
she's looking for pia it's not just her
looking for peta it's her after doing
all these things that she didn't want to
do looking for some sort of humanity
left within herself and that is
represented by four foot one travel size
pita and he's a little pita pocket
but she's also kind of like
his nickname
she's also kind of a badass i mean you
know
i forget which one it was but she she
scales up a tree and she's basically
caught by all the the other kids that
want to kill her and stuff but she
doesn't give up she actually goes she
knocks down this hornet's nest that
screws them all up i'm sorry yeah she's
a manipulated badass because she becomes
the mockingjay at everyone pushing her
you need to do this you need to do this
that's how great heroes are born
she strikes a deal like okay i'll do it
if you go get peanuts
that's the best kind of hero though it's
not the guy that walks into the bar and
thinks he can kick everybody's asses the
ones that's hanging on the corner and
doesn't want to fight but if they have
to use your skills and by the way she
does more than just shoot down a plane
she does it with one arrow too
and she also saves a really cute cat of
course she does yeah thank you blake and
remember when she's trying to get like
sponsors she shoots that arrow right
into where all the rich people are i
mean come on
there's other districts that are going
to rebel against their captors based on
katniss's symbol the mockingjay so if
you want to say the bird is a better
hero than katniss i can listen to that
she's a prop philip seymour hoffman and
president corner pulling all the strings
she's just a mouthpiece all right that
well thank you you stepped up and you
got i think made this more interesting
and took that side i'm sure the fans
will hate you for it but
come at me tweet
i think you all made really valid points
but i think on the defending side mark
swayed me a little bit more sorry
all right with the cat and the reluctant
hero and you just had a few more points
you were close with the fashion that is
a very good point but i also got to give
spence i'm not going to give you the
both points because you didn't win for
the the losing but you made a good point
in the beginning of um
oh i just completely lost my train
thought was lava no you said um that uh
it's a good movie that's that's better
than the movies that exist which i i
actually value your pro argument more
yeah so i'm gonna give you half that i
actually think which is fair and i'm
going to give you uh i give you both
each a point uh for that round
roger you'll be you'll you'll have
another show i'm going to murder you
guys now that's it that's hundred games
right all right dan dan
i think dan has a back check here's
about to clarify so uh spencer gets one
point and mark gets one point yes okay
and then i just took his other point
uh roger the uh katniss in the tree was
from the first hunger games thank you uh
and the critics would seem to there's
been a pretty steep decline first hunger
games movie eighty-nine percent of the
rock tomato second 84 this one 68. so
it's about right they've gone full
hobbit it's just splitting too thin of a
source material into two movies yeah i
don't think they forgot to say that yeah
uh but other than that a clean round
good job guys well roger said that so
point roger all right that's right
yes so basically that matter that round
didn't mean anything it's a wash
all right round two
now this one's fun
uh
obviously the only thing bigger than the
hunger games is what superhero movies
right yeah so what if we combine the two
right let's go there let's figure it out
i'm listening which major superhero
would win the hunger games is our
question now i gotta preface we do prep
a little bit of this in advance because
everybody's got to prepare their
argument they don't know what they're
fighting but i'm gonna give roger a
point off the gate because he picked the
awesomest title uh awesomest choice that
we just all realized there's no way he
would have been beaten and that was dr
manhattan which we all were thinking
superman hulk which i think these will
come up but
it's dr manton just like you can't pick
jesus
oh i did
i i went there and i'm not but i asked
you to pick another one on the sake of
having a good argument here but i'm
going to give you the point for cleverly
out beating us and picking dr manhattan
so rather the guy who doesn't already
gets another huge guy doesn't wear pants
right right so nobody wants to see that
hunger games anyway you don't need to
see that thing flopping conjure all
kryptonite and just
end it at him
i would actually like to see his big
blue wang like killing everyone in the
hunger games just killing everyone yeah
there you go cat is trying to climb it
to find peter to be fair it's actually
the train that they ride in the movie
pete is in this magma
whoa okay so we're going for another
point in this back check that yeah
that will not be fine let's go through
roger you pick you so you get the point
for duck man congratulations thank you
but let's keep going who would you pick
uh aside from dr manhattan uh the
incredible hulk okay and here's why uh
the incredible hulk is the only person
who really has this duality he's bruce
banner who is
genius scientist i mean he can figure
out all kinds of things to do while he's
in there just as bruce banner he's
probably smarter than any of the other
contestants there but if you make him
mad like someone tries to attack him he
becomes the incredible hulk who is just
an unstoppable machine and i'm sorry but
i would love to see katniss shoot an
arrow at the incredible hulk blink
i mean that's just going to be awesome
it would be a well-targeted arrow right
i mean yeah
you cannot really not miss the
incredible hulk at all mark would you
pick trump i was really tempted to go
with aquaman because usually the hunger
games start out on a body of water and
so immediately he could just dive in and
hold his breath and let everybody else
settle that but i thought you know who
else is really good at holding their
breath and a lot of other crap is
superman i mean it's kind of a hacky
answer because he's superman and it was
almost a dr manhattan thing but i think
superman is going to take this pretty
easily
spencer fair enough i'm picking the
ultimate survivor wolverine
so wolverine has a lot of things going
for him he basically can't be killed um
he can regenerate from pretty much
anything to address the hulk when hulk
fought wolverine hulk of course rips him
in two throws his body three miles away
and what does wolverine do he uses his
torso to climb back to his legs
he chooses it he detunes it all the way
back to his lower half unfortunately
bruce banner could just create a
powerful magnet and then wolverine is
kind of oh who's gonna send him the
magnet because here's my other point
against superman uh yeah superman's
probably gonna kick his ass all things
considered but he'll smell him coming he
can hide and then the big part of the
hunger games is appealing to the
sponsors is being entertaining so that
they send you the care packages
wolverine way more fun to watch than
superman the uh the people outside are
going to send him a kryptonite condom or
not from that condo
you're still thinking of dr manhattan
aren't you
kryptonite condom and he will you know
superman right out of those games
interesting i think wolverine's going to
succeed early on in the hunger games
because he does have the survivors
mentality and he can borrow down for a
while but the problem with wolverine is
that eventually it's no longer a selfish
games is that you're no longer fighting
for yourself you're representing your
entire district and superman has
embraced that whether he's home on
planet krypton or he's embraced his new
home of earth he's fighting for the
people that he's done but that's not
what the hunger games want because he's
too powerful then uh you know it's also
morally no listen
superman will not kill anybody and
that's the whole not according to the
whole thing
we're talking about people and superman
will not kill people that is one of the
things about his immediately fly away
right and conquer the right and you're
talking about being entertaining to the
sponsors i'm sorry but a giant hulk
destroying everything rather than
wolverine with a little bit
bruce banner working on his magnets yeah
but again he's not just going to be for
his banner he's going to be fighting
people and as soon as that happens the
sponsor
will win and then go nuts he'll kill
everyone then he'll forget the wolverine
can come back uh first off this is not a
battle between the characters fighting
each other let's let's not forget that
secondly yeah remember the whole thing
this is just the these superheroes
against people no no no no
they're all in the ring together oh now
they're in the ring
in the ring again look the hulk has a
lot of special ring together the problem
is that when the hulk gets hulked out
that takes some time for him to re for
him to find his bearings and you can
totally distract a huge hulk you can if
you like something on fire the hulk is
going to go run towards that then you've
got a whole back shot you can fly into
totally you can fly to death you can't
easily flank the hulk very easy no and
you can't it's you can flight you can
knock him down and stuff he's just going
to get up even more angrier and stronger
than before
you can kill him he'll come back he's
like a horror movie you can't kill the
hulk either you can't kill wolverine
bruce banner tried killing himself and
it didn't work so hold on hold on let me
roll the reins in here what i'm
listening for things that i can then use
to put the story in my head of the most
sensible battle that's going to go down
so just keep throwing them out but i'm
just warning you i'm listening to each
of the things that you're saying
who's who's ultimately going to win that
battle
i'm saying i'm saying the hulk will win
uh the reason i think he superman i
don't think will win just because he
will not kill people he will not kill
people and the reason wolverine will not
win yeah they're equal maybe physically
and all like they both can't be
destroyed but bruce banner is way
smarter than wolverine
destroyed when he's bruce back he cannot
destroy he's tried killing himself i
know that the hulk will come out
whatever the hulk will kill wolverine
over and over he'll keep coming back
like a horror movie villain you can't
get rid of wolves and you can't
damn dan i need you to check something
for me
cannon of hulk versus superman i believe
they did fight hulk versus don't tell me
yet but i'd like you to just just look
it up for us i want to change my answer
to the punisher no
i think basically superman has the
ability to wait this out so whoever else
is competing in the games is going to
weed each other out thus he doesn't have
to kill anybody else until it's down to
him versus someone else you've got to
play to the audience and the audience is
going to send them kryptonite asap to
get rid of that boring goody two-shot by
the time they fly that kryptonite over
and it drops down in those little
parachutes superman's already gonna have
taken care of everything else and he can
fly away from that kryptonite they're
not gonna make it rain kryptonite
they'll find a way
bruce banner will invent a way he'll
he'll find a way to combine minerals in
that planet to make kryptonite and
magnets
magnets are minerals and there are all
kinds of weird asthma i mean they have
those crazy hornets and stuff in the
movie what's not to say he can't make a
magnet yeah see i see i see bruce banner
in this battle like like jeffrey
wright's character in the hunger games
where he's just going to be hanging out
this nerdy sciences by a beach tinkering
with something perhaps if you can
reverse the force fields and then
someone shoots an arrow at him and he
kills everyone which but then he's not
going to be working on anything anymore
he's just going to be of course because
he won no no that's not how he's going
to get everybody he's going to break a
lot of stuff i'm going to give you that
he's going to break many things and then
he's going to ultimately break your
heart because superman is going to
defeat wolverine and hulk you kill
wolverine comes right back dan do we
have anything on your end yeah uh from
my research it looks like i i found the
source that says that they fought at
least three times and superman has a i
guess what could be called a 201 record
two victories one i think that's the
brothers record as well right uh so
if we're going comics continuity from
their team up superman has the edge in a
one-on-one fight there was a i think
there was one thing with that roger i
think there was a thing where like the
fans actually got to vote yes wasn't it
yeah
it was a fan vote thing and more more
fans voted of course because more fans
know superman than the hulk uh and they
yeah i mean i'll give you that it's like
when they vote in derek jeter into the
all-star game and it's like really i
recognize that name yeah um but i think
that if you go comics uh
hulk versus wolverine
exactly what i said happened he rips him
in half and he comes back
who went who won did was there wait it's
a draw it's a draw yeah so that's what
i'm saying what's your what's your point
i'm saying has wolverine ever fought
superman
that's not fair
it's not fair without kryptonite yeah so
you know stacy marvel but with
kryptonite oh totally fair he's done so
i'm going to play a scenario in my head
out and it might deem the winner it may
not i feel like superman and hulk are
going to go first toe to toe they're
going to have to and i think wolverine
is going to be the one who waits it out
he's going to be katniss in the tree
exactly he can he's got the survival
instincts superman's too proud like
there's no way hulk and superman aren't
going toe-to-toe you don't think you
don't think bruce banner you you your
whole argument was that he was going to
be like tinking around for a while
maybe he's the one hiding
he's smart who wins versus superman and
hulk and i feel like it is ultimately
superman's probably going to win that
one yeah i i think i just picked the
right superheroes
superman they created superman before
they created any of these other
superheroes you guys are talking about
and they're like let's just give them
all the superpowers i think it's a wash
because all these superheroes are
unkillable they all come back hear me
through process of elimination i'm going
to give it to superman over hulk and
then hulk's out of the picture hear me
through so far but what if bruce banner
invents magic because superman is
vulnerable to magic of course i could be
wrong but i gotta make it we gotta have
someone trying to make me a sense of
this mess so then it's superman versus
wolverine and what i think would have
happened is i like what you said i think
the tributes would have given him
kryptonite
i think superman's wiped out a hulk and
then i think wolverine pulls a sneaky
shoots him with some arrows and
superman's down here's the thing i think
wolverine could pull it off what if lex
what if lex luthor was one of the
tributes that would be fun dan am i
crazy in that breakdown
listen
uh
serious business i don't say this
lightly this is the nerdiest
conversation we've ever had
uh i listen
that's just as as reasonable as any
other scenario that you can conquer well
luckily i'm the judge so i make the call
yeah tell us in the comments how wrong i
was go ahead but spencer i'm gonna give
it to you
i like the tributes giving them
kryptonite and i think
it came down to if if he didn't hulk
probably would have i don't know they
would probably just kept going forever
and knowing whatever i think superman is
so tired of hearing the kryptonite
argument i think that he's going in
there with some sort of kryptonite proof
whatever that he could that the tributes
can give him uh i love wolverine's
survival instinct when you know that's
one quick clarification it's not the
tributes that are sending things sorry
it's the it's the outside of the body
yeah the fan
the tributes are the ones that are well
screwed all you guys uh the big big blue
big blue wang is coming for you
all right round three
round three
this is a fan question from i love
micheline on youtube who asked a
wonderful question i think actually in
honor of the hunger games which is being
part three what is the best third
installment in a franchise
this is a fun one i want to get to it
there's so many options that it could be
and we are starting with mark i feel
like i took the superman answer in this
one too return of the jedi it's the
greatest trilogy of all time it's the
perfect close to the greatest trilogy of
all time and it has a happy ending and
i'm tired of people saying empire is the
better movie simply because oh it's
darker and it's an oh it doesn't end
happy i like a happy ending especially
when i'm watching a space opera return
of the jedi has that great party after
they destroy the second death star lando
redeems himself so that's a good point
for minorities and i think that the
return of the jedi
it's a huge thing because i'm writing
that down not for a point but just to
remember that you said that
everybody's wondering this moment for
three years it wasn't is darth vader
actually scott walker's father would say
is this lando guy going to be good or is
he going to be bad he ends up being
great he's clutch he can speak niem-nums
language when they're in the millennium
falcon at the end that's a big point
adam lagpark must have known that we got
one of the all-time great quotes from
admiral ackbar it's a trap
to see luke skywalker fulfill the
promise and become a jedi knight and
redeem his father
are you excited for the new movies i
cannot wait
you know what i'm not even excited for
the new movie yet i'm just excited for
the trailer i just want to see your
trailer that's all i need spencer best
third movie uh fast and the furious
tokyo drift no i'm kidding i'm kidding
that was a joke i just want to see what
he would do
my actual pick is uh goldfinger which is
the third james bond movie and no it's
not a trilogy but they asked the third
installment yes so it's the ultimate
james bond movie you've got q in the
gadgets you've got an amazing villain in
auric goldfinger i expect you to die mr
bond he's like the classic bond villain
he has the classic uh odd job sidekick
who is like he doesn't even say a word
and he's amazing so you have everything
that goes into a great bond move you
have sean connery which is necessary
yeah sure the man now
he it's the first appearance of the uh
the aston martin with the missiles
behind the headlights it's got um it
actually has like a cool twist at the
end when you realize he's not trying to
rob fort knox he's trying to irradiate
it so like it's a smarter uh plot than
your usual james bond fair and uh it's
the first time he says uh the martini
line shaking out sir it's just when you
put a james bond movie in a time capsule
it's gonna be goldfinger
so if you like changing choices roger
best third movie all right uh i think
i'm going with the underdog here but i
absolutely believe this halloween three
season of the witch that is the underdog
yes yes yes
all right so halloween three season of
the witch is when they left the michael
myers story line behind it it's a
completely separate movie from
everything and basically the story is uh
there's a toy maker in a toy factory who
wants to play a prank on all the
children of the world and the prank is
he's going to murder them with killer
halloween masks
yeah so they put on these masks and then
they watch this this tv screen that
plays this little three more days till
halloween halloween halloween three more
days till halloween silver shamrock and
then they die their faces melt
there's a little chip in the back of the
masks that has elements
you're talking yourself out of this one
no no no i'm talking everyone into
watching this trust me dr manhattan
cannot say
no absolutely there's a chip in the back
of the mask that has the silver shamrock
logo on but it has elements of
stonehenge in it and stonehenge has some
strange old magic in it that interacts
with these computers and that's what
causes these kids to die and not it's
not just their faces melting it causes
bugs and snakes to crawl out of them all
kinds of crazy stuff that's like dan
is this now the nerdiest conversation
ever yeah
i'm just not even mentioning the android
right right
i was getting to it thank you thank you
so in addition to the killer mess he he
he doesn't trust anyone to work for him
at the toy factory so he built all these
android toy man now i see why you liked
interstellar
i would have rather had the android toy
man from the movie than that big blocky
thing but that's getting sidetracked all
right well that is
no way
yeah so so
these androids they're like powered by
like this yellow goo and stuff and they
rip off a bum's head for basically just
saying like he's going to burn down the
toy factory so they just get there and
rip off his head they put a drill in
some nurses that's all the first five
minutes yes this is it's it's an amazing
movie and i really appreciated it
because they were doing something gutsy
at the time i mean michael myers was
huge back then and to actually
completely abandon it and try something
new that's awesome and what they wanted
to do with this was every halloween they
wanted to make a new halloween movie
that was a completely original story but
since the movie bombed in the theaters
which i wonder why i wonder why yeah
back then back then people didn't have
an open mind we did everything
back then they didn't have an open mind
about it they're all so bored like we
did everything right they went bad the
yellow goo
right they went back they went back to
the michael myers story after that but i
think i think it's a big mistake because
it would have been great to see all
these original halloween movies every
year right stay in the canon do they
mention three in the other movies ever
uh no in in part three they play a
little bit of uh of the other halloween
movie while he he's got his last five
has three ever mentioned again no it's
like a bad weed dream you're like nope
you never know does halloween four start
out with patrick duffy in the shower and
they're like nah no that's never
happened halloween 4 is like the best
like the creepiest halloween intro uh of
all the halloween movies but we'll we'll
talk about that some other time all
right so goldfinger versus jedi no no
no
i do want to watch that now i mean i am
so intrigued like you if you were trying
to pitch why we should watch one of
these movies on netflix everybody's seen
gold you'd win the netflix argument but
i'll also tell you this is it i i
respect the hell out of you for backing
i know right
there's my point right there for you you
elevated it to all madden toughness okay
but the magic of stonehenge is
insignificant next to the power of the
force nope so you guys skipped a lot i
mean no prisoner of activar no toy story
no dire with a vengeance uh so
but you no return of the king no tom
atkins amazing mustache in halloween
three i mean
what's just saying yeah yeah my problem
is i i haven't seen it so it's hard for
me you sold it for me well
but with goldfinger jedi
i i like he he made a very interesting
point of it it introduced so many new
things where jedi was a nice conclusion
she wraps it up nice it was not the best
star wars movie not knocking it but i i
uh so some why was jedi such a fantastic
you know because it's great to start
something bond continues to keep going
and going and going and it's a really
neat adventure to watch a spy who has a
lot of stds by this point continue to
travel the world and fight evil doers
but return of the jedi did the hardest
thing to do in film which is have a nice
close to a great franchise it is so hard
to put a nice book in onto something
that we all know and love i mean look at
the prequels they all came out we were
really excited because it's more star
wars not as easy to do isn't it
is it a booking we're continuing now we
get to open that [ __ ] why is
everybody excited because return of the
jedi was so great it's like goldfinger
started something great and then we had
some good movies some bad movies some
good bonds some bad bonds but return of
the jedi sealed the deal as star wars
being the greatest trilogy and franchise
in film history spencer yeah you can
still throw some darts at it a it's not
empire and b there's ewoks in it why
does everybody attack you knew it was
going to come up there's the e1 i don't
understand why people hate them
they are very adorable why is cuteness a
bad thing it's not a bad thing it's just
kind of a cheapening of what was a
otherwise amazing uh serious thing
attacking the ewoks is an easy target i
mean that's that's been done a million
times there though we can't just cover
our eyes to the ewoks i know we can't
they're tough little creatures fighting
on their home turf it's kind of like
sticks and stones
the empire went there and they weren't
prepared for the terrain and the ewoks
used there
my my point is this the ewoks are not as
logical as halloween three i'm sorry
let's call ewoks for what they were they
were toys they were they introduced toys
which they kenner at the time we need
more toys george there were some muppets
in there designed and they were adorable
they were adorable but were they really
additive to the story or were they
marketing at edition is what i i i do
you know challenge that a little bit
yeah i thought they were i thought they
were integral to the story because it's
showing that you don't have to be this
big bad evil force to win you can be
good and you can be cute and cuddly and
still triumph over evil plus there's a
very the most emotional scene in any
star wars movie is when that e1 dies
and i guarantee you don't have anything
that heart-wrenching in goldfinger well
okay
not that uh heart-wrenching true but i
think it gives kids unrealistic
expectations of resisting uh the empire
because that was so futile and to think
that you can fight back with sticks and
stones against atats is just setting up
kids for a lifetime of letdowns
and and to think that you can fight back
against an evil toy maker trying to ruin
halloween
these are two perfect movies you can
nitpick star wars uh but you can't
nitpick goldfinger uh unless you just
straight up don't like james bond i mean
these are two great movies going up
against each other oh this is tough uh
yeah just go with halloween three yeah
respect points not actual points for the
for the argument i give you like 10
respect points
through the roof on sticking that your
guns in that but i just can't i can't
pick it over the other two but i don't
know what's tough
with those
i'm just curious where where your
leanings go uh i was much more of a star
wars fan than a james bond fan as much
as i loved sean connor
uh so i would i would lean to star wars
on that one uh just because it meant
more to me uh that's where i'm at too
but i gotta give spencer some props
because i feel like you made an amazing
point the sidekick i mean trunk iron is
great but the ashton martin the twist
the martinis like those things that were
one that defines the series where star
wars
didn't really actually set the tone for
the remainder of the movies and so while
my guts are saying well of course you go
with jedi i gotta sort of lean the goal
finger but i'm my guy can't go away from
jedi so i'm gonna give you both points
okay oh yeah all right all right so is
this like round one where i got a point
two
come on uh damn that bonus point don't
forget yeah dan fact check that you're
you're only both leading spencer by one
so it's actually still a close game
uh yeah i had just a couple of
clarifications there halloween three is
awesome yeah we know that first for andy
uh prisoner of akka bar sounds like a
fun movie but it's it's uh prisoner of
azkaban
uh that would be a great movie this is
super ticky tacky you said that the
ewoks were fighting uh 8080s with
and mark ellis uh with your patrick
duffy reference congratulations you made
the first dallas reference
notice he's not correcting any of my
things about halloween three because
that is a perfect movie and he knows
that everything is there
all right round four round four
uh casting for the young jean grey and
cyclops has begun for x-men apocalypse
uh they're uh saying chloe moretz al
fanning hallie stanfield and a bunch of
guys i actually don't know ben hardy
eastenders um do we need a young uh
cyclops and jean grey and x-men
apocalypse that's our fight number four
number four uh what do you guys think uh
we're starting with spencer yeah i think
so i mean aside from the comics thing
that i won't spoil cyclops plays a
fairly big role in the fight against
apocalypse so it makes sense to bring
him back but really we have a whole new
chance to right the wrongs of x one
through three and i think one of the
major lacking things was cyclops was
just reduced to this one-dimensional
preppy jerk he was just a foil for like
wolverine's game on on jean grey and
he's actually a more interesting
character than that he was like an
orphan of course he's a superhero and he
was raised by like a criminal that made
him do crimes and he uh you know he's a
reluctant leader so there's more depth
to him than they've uh than you would
think if you just watch x one through
three and then jean grey like
her her story could fill like seven
guardians of the galaxy she's going out
in a space she's interacting with
psychic beings and it just gives them
another chance to reintroduce us to some
characters that have a lot more death to
them than you would think from the
original trilogy
roger
no uh and i say this because i just want
to see quicksilver in the next movie and
that's it i want i want 90 minutes of
quicksilver in slow motion setting up
this amazing
uh prank on everybody i guess kind of
like the toy maker in halloween three
but no no uh
literally 90 minutes of slow motion
quicksilver running around pulling down
people's pants doing whatever the hell
he's going to do and then see a lot of
that between the flash show and
quicksilver and ultron we're going to
see a lot of that and then the last 30
minutes is when you know it goes back to
normal speed and we see everything fall
down 30 minutes of this insane domino
effect that he just destroyed everything
that was the most entertaining thing
about the last movie that quicksilver
scene so i just want to see more of that
i i i don't care about cyclops or jean
grey uh in this next movie i just want
quicksilver yeah i because i think that
x-men day is a future past just not
enough mutants no i think that you
definitely need cyclops angie and gray
in x-men apocalypse because even if
you're not sticking strictly to the
source material with the comic books
you're going up against apocalypse you
need all hands on deck for this and
including the very underused cyclops
charlie rose a perfect choice to play
him going forward haley steinfeld i
think is going to make the best gene
gray going forward she's one of those
powerful mutants you need her brain on
board when you're going up against
apocalypse she looks like the logical uh
former famke janssen so i think that
she's the perfect choice to play jean
grey and i think they've already set the
groundwork of introducing you to all the
x-men like you said there's enough
mutants in it already but i feel like
they've done the work with first class
and days of future past that we all know
magneto and mystique and professor x and
wolverine like we can introduce two or
three new ones in this one and look
here's the thing too is that i like
x-men first class a lot but i'm i'm kind
of sick of these junior varsity mutants
thinking that they're real x-men i want
to get a little butterfly wings yeah
man it's like it's really cute just go
out and recess somewhere we are fighting
apocalypse now we need that we need
these we need the a-team we need the
ones not only from the comic books from
the cartoon in the early 90s yeah let's
just get animated storm in there
you sold me right there at the end you
get the point
all it takes is hard to win
those are very good i don't want the
junior varsity either i want i want the
main guns spencer made a very valid some
valid points but i gotta i gotta pick
somebody
uh all right moving on that was a quick
one but i think we settled that i think
we do uh roger we do need to see them a
little bit
we're round five
uh starting my clock on mine uh all
right so arnold schwarzenegger says
there's potential a running man sequels
in the making we also know triplets
twins two is in the making uh i wanna
know which sequel do we wanna see
schwarzenegger do what's our dream
schwarzenegger let's say those are up we
don't even know if those are getting
made but let's really fight for it
what's the ultimate dream schwarzenegger
sequel uh roger you're leading us off uh
i'm gonna say running man uh uh
amazing movie and i i don't think it's
given as much credit as as it should be
uh uh you know schwarzenegger of course
people talk about terminator predator uh
running man is a fun movie uh it's it's
him thrown into this game
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying it's
it's it predates uh battle royale and
all so uh
already set some things for that but
uh the great thing about is it also
inspired smash tv which is one of the
best arcade games so many chords such a
fun arcade game uh it inspired that and
there are incredible characters in in
the running man because you know you've
got like diamond uh not dimino dynamo uh
he's this opera singer who rides around
in a dune buggy and can arc lightning
and just so funny while he's while he's
singing opera it's it's amazing and you
you've got jesse ventura in it uh which
i'm always on board for uh him and
schwartz now you're in a movie together
uh and you've got these other
competitors like the guy with the
chainsaw and uh you've got the blowtorch
dude it's just a fun side note the
ending to the book it's a little too 911
so they kept it up but he flies a jet
into the uh tv network giving the middle
finger in the cockpit to the head i wish
they
speaking of jesse ventura and arnold
schwarzenegger in a movie together i
gotta see arnold in another predator
movie before it's all said and done
because predator the first one is so
great with him leading this team into
the jungle to fight this mysterious
thing that's attacking them it's picking
his team off one by one we could still
see arnold and carl weathers reunite and
i think that the predator is such a
great character that just hasn't gotten
his due in a good film since arnold was
with him i really liked the predators
movie with adrian brody and it's a
perfect way to bring arnold back into
that world if arnold is the next boat of
survivors that gets flown down so
basically you're saying predator
expendables is what you want i don't
want i lit on one of those other guys i
mean i wasn't saying that in a mean way
yeah i mean like
that's pretty much the precursor to
expendables that is that helicopter
scene at the beginning but i i think
that arnold i mean like bring bringing
them all back bring in jesse ventura car
weather bring them all back in their old
age yeah to fight a predator
is gonna come back there's gonna have to
be some plot mechanics where he's
playing his twin brother right yeah yeah
because he's yeah yeah yeah arnold's the
only one who'd come back yeah
they would have to have like a ghost
like they could have like the the four
the blue force around him helping arnold
fight this pressure it's just like his
arm that's it just says it's carl
weather's arm on a robot maybe future
predators brought them back to life damn
let me spin the scenario for favor
in the predators film when adrian brodie
and then they find that that mysterious
wreck shift ship they go in there and
they see that lawrence fishburne has
been living in there what if instead of
lawrence fishburne that was arnold oh
man
the entire theater would have erupted
that is what you want to see because
look i think the running man's great a
lot of arnold stuff is great but it
doesn't stand the test of time as well
as predator which is one of the greatest
action movies of all time arnold
schwarzenegger is known for being the
greatest action star of all time let's
get these two hooked up again yeah but
more about this but i gotta spend your
time in a predator does stand the test
of time and uh he is the greatest action
star ever but we gotta face the facts
it's 2014. he's in his mid-60s he can't
carry an action movie by himself as
we've seen with last stand and whatever
the swat one was that i didn't see
not escape plan it was even rent anyways
i think it was called squad right
i think it was called jingle all the way
all the way so why not go with one
that's a little bit action that you can
give them but also some comedy in true
lies two false lies
so
so arnold arnold is grown up so at the
end of that he and jamie lee curtis are
both secret agents and uh
it was all about having that double life
so how about this time it's the daughter
still played by eliza dushku is the uh
is living a double life as a secret
agent they don't know about it she gets
kidnapped on her honeymoon whatever with
maybe tom lennon maybe patton oswalt is
the unknowing husband and then arnold
oh i'll get there i'll get there they
have to come out of retirement from
being spies to rescue their so you
basically want taken with i want a
funnier i want a comedy taken with
arnold schwarzenegger jamie lee curtis
and of course helping them along the way
tom arnold i don't think you can do a
straightforward serious action movie
with uh with arnold at this point it'll
just be depressing what about sinbad you
could throw him in there
and you have to have bill paxton's
character return too right yeah
wow i mean does anyone not want to see
any of these
i would i would pay money i'd pay money
to see all three of these movies but i
think the one that the fans really need
to see is the is another predator that's
good i mean look predator 2 was pretty
terrible the coolest thing about
predator 2 is oh look that's the alien
yeah i think i think predator
the first predator is awesome movie but
it's tired now we've we've all seen the
predator who else is tired arnold is
tired arnold is tired but i would pay
money to see him just embarrassed in in
that spandex outfit that he had to wear
in the running man
i want to see old schwarzenegger running
around in that spandex with his gut
hanging out and everything i want that i
think it's like so many great athletes
that you see over the years that they
lose their fastball but they still have
one more great game in them and i think
that putting arnold in a predator movie
is that game i think i think i'm in true
light you're not asking that much of
them you just ask them to be funny and
do some action which you can hide with
clothing yeah but none of those movies
have an opera singer who gets defeated
by uh a water yeah a fire water they
killed him off already he's not guys
you're all talking you're all helping
each other at the end of the day we
gotta i i called it up at the end of the
day
i gotta give us all the points cause i
wanna see all those movies i don't i
just i can't fight any of those those
arguments because i want to see them all
but and you were close you're close to
winning it all but he is a little old i
don't your pitch of him being in
predators was perfect that would have
been perfect but they didn't do it so
it's frustrating
so i don't know how you fix it now
because it's like they should have done
that but anyway points to everybody
there's another useless round but a very
fascinating conversation i want to see
those movies for for everyone at home
that's what that's round five right yeah
we've now given out eleven points
through five yeah we all win right it's
like ayso this is like sport everybody
gets a sportsmanship participation for
pizza after the podcast all right round
six
it's another fan question bae nintendo
on twitter asks
uh can the cgi peanuts movie be good
which brings what i want to create a new
recurring segment on movie fights which
is trailer fights
so we all watch the trailer uh we all
know peanuts growing up snoopy charlie
brown uh and this trailer came out what
do we think did is it blasphemy do we
think it's actually holding true to the
schultz brand uh let's start with mark
it's uh totally not blasphemy it does
hold true to the schultz brand and i
think that the reason why the peanuts
movie is going to be so good is because
we all love peanuts when we were kids
and growing up there's other things that
we loved like the smurfs that they
completely ruined and took away from the
source material and what we all loved
about them in the first place getting to
see that and getting to see how not to
mess up something from our childhood is
why the new peanuts movie is going to be
really good it's not going to make the
same pitfalls that its cartoon friends
did
spencer okay you know i was on board
with it for like the first 15 seconds of
the trailer where the you know you see
snoopy the 3d animation doesn't look
terrible and then and the vince coralie
theme is playing and then it like comes
to a record scratch and they start this
music hey that's what i like about you
like it could not be further from what i
loved about peanuts which was simplicity
and a certain kind of like handcrafted
quality when we're going like through
these 3d dive bombs through um the
eiffel tower nowhere when i was watching
the penis i think like this needs to be
an immersive visual experience that's
what this is missing is dog fighting um
so there's that going on for it and then
really it's just like this is also a
christmas movie so it's going to be
compared to charlie brown christmas
which is perfect there is no need to
make another christmas uh peanuts movie
i'm really sad that they're trying to go
up against their own best movie
roger uh also the biggest thing to me is
schultz is not actually involved with
this that charlie was no his name is
attached to him yeah and not he's still
alive no no
um
so that's already a big point against it
for me but his family is involved
correct yeah
look uh what what spencer said is is
also true about uh you know we we don't
need this big technological thing the
thing the thing that makes the peanuts
awesome is it feels like it's something
like they got an entire elementary
school together to just put all their
resources and just make something uh it
sounds you can almost hear like kids
reading off of paper scripts as they're
doing it's it's awkward it's not
professional voice actors doing this
it's it's it's that simplicity it's it's
the piano music you don't want to hear
any crazy uh you know pop beats or
anything going on you just want that
simplicity throughout the whole movie
and i i think that's the kind of thing
that's going to be uh taken away with
this you don't need 3d graphics you
don't need to be able to count the pores
on snoopy's nose as he spirals through
the first just because it's updated
technology doesn't mean the kids can't
gravitate towards i think the kids will
more so today because kids today do not
care about the old school animation that
we grew up watching and so if you want
to enjoy the same thing that your kids
are going to enjoy peanuts this new one
is going to be the way to do it now god
forbid i ever have kids i'd rather have
them with some good clean fun which is
what this new peanuts is gonna be than
having it you know then having them
watch some other cartoons i have more
faith than kids that if you show them
old peanuts things they'll still love it
i mean there's a reason that stuff still
airs on tv and kids love it too too this
day they they're
yeah but the kids love it put down that
game boy for two seconds and watch the
christmas sit through this love it the
kids absolutely love it and that's why
it continues to go on and it will go on
well past our generation and any other
one let us have something kids don't eat
everything
it's interesting i'm in the i'm on the
fence this because i i agree totally
what you're saying but i thought what
they did aside from the dance music good
point aside from that i thought it was
updated enough or it didn't feel like it
was
expensive yeah
they did like a kind of a cool 2d
look that to me felt like all right you
got to update a little bit for this
audience sadly you do and i don't want
those characters to go away and and it's
a little too early to say are they
really going to throw in the dance music
the whole time or was that just the
trailer to get them in the theaters it's
a trailer fight
so this is so yes fair damn i'm sorry uh
the schultz family i did look it up his
charles schultz's son and grandson did
write
the movie so it is from
it's from the family but it's not
schultz himself and and naturally you
know the sun continue to make a buck so
i'm sure they're doing whatever the
subject matter it's i mean that was just
a different time when peanuts was
written and all and you know that you're
you're gonna take some of that heart out
of the movie with not just the 3d but in
the writing itself because charles
schultz is peanut yeah and clearly
snoopy's gonna be fighting the red baron
like the world war one fighter ace yeah
good luck with the kids i mean that
seems like something that transformers i
mean it's moving incredibly fast just
all kinds of crazy action and you just
don't need that for peanuts update the
graphics if you need to i don't think
you do but
it doesn't have to be so incredibly fast
and you know just explosions and
whatever going on but that's also what a
trailer is that's going to excite kids
to go to the movies yeah but it's a
trailer showing footage from the movie
it i mean i i know that they're going to
add stuff i mean maybe the dance music
isn't in the movie but the trailer
itself vince carolli is not around to
write a new score right also so
i i it's trailer fights right so i think
i want to give you the point because i
agree with them i hope i have faith for
the movie but for a trailer they
probably shouldn't put the dance music
they probably shouldn't update
them updating the romantic song
they could have had some fun faster
piano music maybe got somewhere remix
the original thing song from herbie gets
the point for calling out the music
because i agree in a trailer fight we
got to just talk about the trailer yeah
that was a good point
okay spencer good job
round seven
what if there was stonehenge magic in
the new
oh i'm i'm there i am watching snoopy's
head so another trailer can you wait can
you imagine like if they actually put
the halloween three masks on the peanuts
and you see their heads explode with
snakes and everything
someone out there needs to make that and
tribute
all right round seven another trailer
drop today uh cinderella the live action
update which is now the new hot disney
trend is to update all of their movies
into live-action tim burton looking big
fairy tales although i will see that one
looked a little bit more magical it
looks like they're sticking to the story
i they showed a lot but we know the
story so it didn't offend me but um
rather than trailer flight that one
we're gonna talk about something else
which disney movie uh animated movie
should be made into a live-action film
there's a lot more to pick from and i
imagine eventually they will all be
tackled at some point or another jungle
books in the play i think some others uh
let's let's start uh with you spencer
which disney animated film would you
actually like a live action update
there's a lot more to pick from but
they're burning through them real fast
at an alarming rate and i think by
process of elimination the only ones
left that don't have like animals in
them or haven't been done already is
basically like aladdin and the little
mermaid and aladdin gun is going to be
kind of like weird and offensive so i'm
going to go with the little mermaid um
which will also be weird animals in that
how do you make a cute real looking crab
uh you know you they did it with babe
they'll do it with this i think that
what you do is um
the best two roles in disney
animation could be ariel and ursula and
that's an amazing chance to cast a uh
a really hot 18 year old ariel instead
of 15 or 16 and she was in the movie and
ursula could just be the role of a
lifetime for any uh big actress so
i'm excited about that and i think that
there actually is more to the story that
they can go into because it's based on
hans christian andersen's uh source
material where there's a lot more going
on it's a little darker but it's also a
little more interesting there's more
interaction with her sisters there's um
there's more to play with than uh just a
remake of cinderella so i would see the
little mermaid interesting roger
um i would go with wally uh i want to
see real robots and i was at kamikaze
shooting a video the other week and
there was a guy who built a genuine
wall-e it had all the sounds it worked
perfectly and i could totally see that
in a movie and i mean we haven't had
anything you know like that since short
circuit i was going to say they made
that movie it's called short circuit no
i want short circuits i'm going to make
that movie and it was called wall-e i
mean didn't it look pretty damn close
already like you wanted no i mean what
do you gain that was animated i want to
see your picture looks real to me and
it's particularly i mean even fred uh
will fred willard uh it's will fred
willard the actor who played the
president um
plays himself live action in the movie
so i'm just confused like what's the
translation going to look like a real
robot a cheap johnny five-looking robot
i mean he looked like he looked right
here right here
that's that's what i want to see it
doesn't look real wally looked real and
it's so current i'm just trying to
understand your vision of what what's
the live action wally actually does it
deteriorate from the screen
no i just want a live-action version of
wally
instead of with these weird blobby
cartoony people interacting with real
people
i mean
when you have it i can tell you you
don't like that but no i just i think
it's it felt real to me already i just i
think it felt real would you would you
shoot it shot for shot like psycho
the first 30 minutes you're just going
to be like a weird robot rumbling around
a jump yard and i want to watch
cockroaches i want to watch it
so much
listen it'll be better than battlebots
okay that's all i want nothing will be
better than battlebots
mark i think if you're if you want to
make a disney live action movie you want
to capture that disney magic the classic
feel and i think pinocchio is the way to
go with that because you got this guy he
obviously can't find a suitable mate so
he builds his own ulta
yeah and but there's a way to do that
where as he's becoming a real boy you
learn all these lessons about what it is
to become a real human being and be a
real man and i think you can really have
fun with the whale scene when they're
all stuck inside the whale that's going
to be a fun action piece when they make
them sneeze to shoot them out of the
whale's mouth and when they go to that
creepy island and you see the lost boys
they're turning into donkeys that's
going to really really scare kids into
doing the right thing and don't smoke
cigarettes yeah so i love that they do
they did too right
taylor johnson taylor thomas
attempted and roberto benini was in one
where he played geppetto
how is yours different it's good yeah
it's the big difference
there were talks last year about how
robert downey jr was interested in this
project if ben stiller directed it and i
don't hate that team being involved with
something like this i think that it
could be
downey would be geppetto yeah yeah and
then and and look and it'd be a really
neat thing to see the actual live action
with the cgi have the nose growing we
can watch that right now
we can go put on roxanne with steve
martin that's that's your pinocchio
right there
no one's seen that movie clearly
corrections fun fact about that uh
actually roberto benini played pinocchio
which was made even creepier and that
version of pinocchio came in 2002 is one
of the rare movies out there that has a
whopping zero percent so we can all
together
we can only go out you can literally not
do any worse than that yeah see and like
i mean you know i i think my idea with
the wally movies that the coolest thing
about wally was seeing how fat humans
got and it's hard to do that live action
without i think it's pretty easy to do
that
mccarthy in that chair
it's gonna feel it it's gonna feel
really weird to see them i think it's
gonna feel weirder to see that than just
to see a live boy turn from a puppet
well i don't mean to to throw your ugly
i said i don't it felt live action
already i mean i know it wasn't but
picks are so good now that it's like
they
may find you can't make find nemo with
real fish you'd have to see there's
there's no cgi that exists i have to see
jerry the cop yeah but listen listen
there's no cgi that exist and no you
don't you they have robot cockroaches
and movies and stuff they can totally do
that isn't that what they did with like
joe's apartment a lot of those yeah
stop motion animations yeah there you go
uh no but there's no cgi that exists
that is as
uh any better than a tangible object and
stuff people interact i see the same
thing and it's gonna be way more
expensive to make it where i feel like
pixar did it so well i don't need to see
that pinocchio and little mermaids where
i'm debating between how do you make the
fish and the si and the crab cute are
they cartoony looking yeah i think that
you do have to make a very big
delineation between what it looks like
under the sea and what it looks like on
the surface that the sea can be a mix of
cgi you have to because there's sea
horses pulling people around and stuff
like that so that real life crab does
not look cute
no what the hell are you talking about
yeah
i really like crap have you seen fiddler
crabs they can be adorable
talk underwater can they how do you how
do you live actually make them talk
underwater without you put them in the
same way they did with gravity where i
don't know how they did with gravity but
the same way they did with gravity is
you have the uh the hair floating around
in zero g and uh you film it that way i
trust that they can pull it off
technically it's just more fun to have
like you said melissa mccarthy or adele
or susan uh the american idol winner as
ursula just is it a musical susan boyle
use the same songs yeah definitely um
here's the problem though is that live
action when that priest gets an erection
at the end of the movie it's gonna be
really they can do that for real um so
maybe you spend more time on the surface
uh but i think that that has the best
chance of being do you still hide a
penis in the poster of course it's
disney okay yeah peanut butter stuck
because i feel like i've seen the
pinocchio remake tell me again quickly i
have to wrap this up why is it different
than the other two because when you saw
the cinderella trail you got that
feeling of disney magic live action you
can do the same thing with pinocchio
where's the little mermaid i think it
just gets too clunky because they have
to talk underwater it's an underwater
kingdom and when you try to talk your
friend underwater it's just it becomes a
comedy of errors it's like the fight
scene a top secret in the the corral
there's nowhere to go and so you have to
have all the action above the surface
and if it's above the surface suspension
that this bait is going to get harpooned
splash i don't want to see anything
i like the short singing one i don't
want to see any of these movies am i
allowed to not give a point dan you're
the judge
you've given away so many i don't think
i want to give a point on that round
because i don't want to encourage any of
those what's your answer judge judge
judy over here i didn't prepare okay
halloween
halloween three weeks
congratulations
take it deserve it dan how about you do
you have one that you would pick oh man
any night of the jungle that was a tough
one yeah we got a bunch of jungle book
movies i don't know i mean
it's they're all like fairy tales and
stuff it seems like they've all been
done yeah we don't need that we don't
need any of them
all right overall is a dumb question
because we don't need any of them that's
my fault i take the blame
haters round eight final round let's
zoom through this we're way past our
deadline hopefully the people next door
don't mind we're taking another minute
uh here we go
round eight this is again the tease for
this week's honest trailer so you did
hear it if you're actually watching the
show
uh i will tease that next week's trailer
is british romantic and a christmas
movie with an epic ensemble cast
well british and romance i'm on board so
yeah hopefully with those clues you can
there should only be one it's pretty
lovely actually
so we're gonna take the ensemble cast
theme and say what is the best movie
with an ensemble cast so we gotta
breathe through this because we're
running out of time uh start with you
roger quickly uh true romance is the
ultimate ensemble cast uh there's i i
just don't see how you can have a better
ensemble cast with a good movie like
it's an excellent movie and that's a
rare thing with ensemblecast as far as
i'm concerned so good you have
christopher walken and dennis hopper in
one of the most memorable scenes ever uh
you have uh patricia arquette you have
christian slater you have gary oldman as
drexel the pimp the pam who's incredible
i mean he's like a chameleon of course
uh you also have balckey
from perfect strangers
oh yeah an inspector
right yeah exactly so you have that
excellent choice you have james
gandolfini before james gandolfini was
big he was actually threatening yeah
right it was awesome it's just
a very good choice
i'm going with jfk because oliver stone
made a masterpiece and uh it not only is
is kevin costner the greatest jim
garrison in the lead his entire family
[ __ ] space sack is in it gary oldman
plays lee harvey oswald and does such a
creepy rendition of the old man and
there's so many
they're not even cameos they're really
parts that are integral to the story
that oliver stone is trying to tell
tommy lee jones joe pesci walter matthau
and jack lemmon and john candy are in
these roles where they're not comedic
it's it's taking these incredible actors
and giving them something else to do
that it's outside of their wheelhouse
and it all combined to make one of the
most incredible films and really
thought-provoking movies that i've ever
seen and the the the pista resistance
donald sutherland on the park bench
telling jim garrison what a black op is
and how the jfk assassination was a
black op donald sutherland can convince
me of anything he could have told me
that kennedy was shot by stonehenge
magic in halloween and i'd be like well
i guess that's how the government did it
it's a chip it's a moving film to watch
and it would not be that way without all
these incredible performances that
oliver stone got spencer i'm gonna pick
uh x-men days of future past even though
i like both of the movies you guys
mentioned better i think it just beats
you down with sheer numbers i mean there
are so many people so many famous people
in this movie do you have like pretty
cool actors like j-law and hugh jackman
and anna paquin and james mcavoy and
halle berry and then you get butt wait i
know you're already exasperated but then
you get to even better people like
fassbender and then you throw in
dinklage and then you throw in patrick
stewart and then you throw an ian
mckellen so it just really crosses the
whole span of acting today you have your
legends you have your up and comers and
you have your people in between
well as i just think i i i i think that
both movies have great cast but i just
don't think anything holds up to true
romance as far as being an incredible
movie and great casting and has so many
memorable lines in true romance i mean
you can just pick anything like
christopher walken uh you get me in a
vendetta kind of mood you know it's just
amazing that whole scene with walking in
right oh absolutely i mean that whole
thing it's just perfection and you i i
think in terms of cast and movie you
just cannot get brad pitt on the couch
best role
safari motor motel in yeah
classic jerome's is a great film i just
think that i think the bigger
achievement was taking something that
actually happened and putting all these
famous people into it and not having it
be like oh there's another famous person
there's another famous person but having
all these people really steep into their
characters for the brief time they were
on screen as opposed to being like oh i
recognize that guy in that case i felt a
little bit of that though in jfk where i
feel like it was oliver stone just
putting his friends in and doing it
whereas in true romance they really do
like they are the couches it's like so
it's just so worked and you wouldn't
think it was granted he wasn't right you
didn't know the bread it was i get it
but even now if you watch it i feel like
you still wouldn't know it's brad pitt
and bronson is like as this weeny little
coked out hollywood douche i mean it's
perfect they're they're all good trolls
is the best but i gotta say true romance
really does kill it very good choice
you both make good choices but i can't i
can't knock bronson pincher was in jfk
and that's
roger you did it and you tied with mark
there at the end
uh but spencer eat down again buy an
extra boy
five points to four and four all right
uh nick didn't try spencer's wanted nick
next monday was right uh i i think
you're you're leaning towards him yeah i
know hey wanna pull our points together
yeah you know what we
spencer took the devil's advocate so not
only does he get the win he also gets
the dvd combo yes yes oh i'm watching
both on repeat thank you guys all right
guys we're out of time annoyingly but
thank you so much this was a fun one
really good debates uh what did you guys
think of the show where were we wrong
where was i wrong tell us in the
comments below if you're watching in
youtube more importantly always tell us
what movie fight you want to hear
hashtag it any of our twitters
movie fights plural so we can find it
and we will look and we always look each
week to find your suggestions really
quickly i want to make sure you also go
check us out on itunes please go
subscribe comment uh uh what do you do
when i rate it you can rate it
yeah right yeah all those good things
and actually i as a small myself i want
to thank you guys for being such a great
show on our network now part of the
popco popcorn talk nation uh network
tell us about the popcorn talk nation
it's it's all the shows that you know
from the schmoestner movie network and
we're now that's the flagship brand it's
the popcorn talk network so you can
subscribe to twitter on youtube make
sure you subscribe to me and christian's
channel schmoe's no never pay to see a
bad movie again we loved it it's just
it's passionate movie talk from movie
things i want to add screen duckies you
have to go do that i'm telling you to go
do it go to go to the shmo's no channel
and tell them we sent you and obviously
also go to the popcorn it's youtube.com
popcorntalk network correct yeah please
go there as well lots of fun podcasts
you guys are doing what movie talk i
know that i have the list but you know
even more anatomy of the movie jedi
alliance marvel movie news you have so
many good shows dc movie news show meet
the movie press jedi alliance movie
pleasures and then the shmo's know movie
show every thursday night guys you gotta
go check them out so go support so we
can keep doing this and show them your
love i want to thank our panelists as
well spencer gilbert at spencerj gilbert
on twitter anything else you'd like to
send or plug devil's advocate on dvd
roger barr at imockery on twitter
anything else you'd like to mention oh
yeah it's i m-o-c-k-e-r-y on twitter and
i'm also on youtube uh youtube.com roger
bar and i don't have a copy of halloween
three but you all need to watch it okay
please everyone another watch watch this
movie mark ellis 5150 at ls what do you
what do you got smoz know please check
them out on youtube what else know check
it out and bring some of that stonehenge
magic to the cleveland hilarities after
thanksgiving friday through sunday i'll
be there if you're in the ohio area and
i gotta thank hashtag dan cam uh hashtag
dam cam dam cam dan dan with an n damn
nope damn
dan anything you'd like to plug uh
uh florida state university i feel like
we're on the i feel like i'm on the
howard stern wrap up show right now and
rest in peace mike
did i did i plug halloween three yes you
did
you remember dan who shot kennedy can
you hold that up real quick before we go
uh thank you guys so much we will see
you next week as always please keep
staying tuned and tell us what you want
to see and thanks for watching bye-bye
every podcast we put on youtube comes
with this kick-ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast battle royale go
ahead try them all
if you haven't already subscribe to
screen junkies on youtube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on itunes click the logo to download an
audio version
lastly please support our friends at the
popcorn talk network for more awesome
shows
you